es la presa que Francia llevaba tiempo
intentando pescar en sus redes 40 en
licencias concedidas porque en sí una
medida considerada como una victoria por
la ministra francesa para Asuntos
Marítimos la Comisión Europea y Francia
han avanzado mucho Kongens y en las
últimas semanas nuestros esfuerzos están
dando sus frutos y el trabajo para dar
la máxima visibilidad a los
profesionales continuará
todos podrán pescar en aguas de Jersey
como lo hacían antes del brexit y aunque
esto puede parecer una victoria para
Francia la batalla está lejos de
terminar 111 licencias en su mayoría de
Jessie siguen pendientes Francia ha
criticado a Reino Unido por no haber
expedido los permisos con suficiente
rapidez cuando Reino Unido se retiró de
la Unión Europea las zonas de pesca y su
normativa se fueron con el país ahora
para acceder a determinadas aguas
británicas los pescadores europeos deben
obtener primero una licencia además las
embarcaciones también deben demostrar
que ella pescaban allí entre 2012 y 2016
una normativa problemática para los
navíos más pequeños que a menudo no
disponen de GPS y por tanto no pueden
demostrar su historial de pesca en la
zona en el caso de los barcos más
antiguos que tienen que ser sustituidos
por otros nuevos esa prácticamente
imposible por su parte el gobierno
francés sostiene que tiene la pelota en
su tejado los dos países tienen hasta el
10 de diciembre fecha límite fijada por
la Comisión Europea para resolver esta
disputa antes del lanzamiento de
posibles represalias